any kind of nuclear strike happens  anywhere our world changes overnight and  it just gives you this excuse to roll  out all sorts of Martial law slash  authoritarian measures wherever you know  it wouldn't matter which side it was on  like it like say that happens say 10 000  people get taken out and attack tactical  strike in the Ukraine you don't think  that this Administration here would  utilize that not only to instill fear on  the American public but pass certain  executive orders and measures that would  restrict yeah I mean that's directive 51  you guys know directive 51  um you ever play the game the division  no I never played oh come on that game's  great was there a bush uh directive Bush  director nine after nine and we it was I  think it was in like 2007 we're not sure  if it's legal it's never been tested but  presidential National Security  Presidential Directive 51 allows the  president to basically overwrite the US  government and create a new one the